Episode 4 features some of the biggest
reveals in "Peacemaker" so far.
Will White Dragon armor up
for a big CGI-heavy finale?
Will Vigilante ever find acceptance?
And what's Murn's ultimate goal, anyway?
Towards the end of Episode 4, Peacemaker has
a heart-to-heart with Harcourt in the same bar
where the two chatted in Episode 1. After noting
that Leota knew about his difficult upbringing,
Peacemaker inquires about his file. Harcourt
eventually admits that Peacemaker's file
says that White Dragon trained
him to kill from a very young age
and that Peacemaker was involved in his own
brother's mysterious death. Peacemaker is
clearly disturbed that his "friends" have such
intimate knowledge of one of his worst memories.
Returning home, Peacemaker lights up a bong
and dances while "House of Pain" by Faster
Pussycat plays in his trailer. Sadly, the
music appears to be a limited comfort to
the emotionally scarred superhero. A series of
flashbacks show a mullet-wearing White Dragon
forcing a young Peacemaker to
kill a man tied to a chair.
As Peacemaker also remembers killing Rick Flag in
"The Suicide Squad," he collapses to the ground,
where Eagly and Goff study him as he mourns the
loss of his brother many decades earlier. No
doubt we'll find out exactly who's responsible
for his brother's death in a future episode.
Episode 4 is where we see Leota's natural
ability as an intelligence officer shine.
Because White Dragon has become such
a haunting force in Peacemaker's life,
Leota subtly suggests that Vigilante murder
the white supremacist leader. Her skill at
manipulating Vigilante to do her bidding is
markedly reminiscent of that of her mother, Amanda
Waller. However, Leota's skills go well beyond
the manipulation of a psychopath like Vigilante.
Upon returning to the team's headquarters, Leota
and Peacemaker discover that Judomaster has
escaped, incapacitated John Economos, and is on
the run. Peacemaker engages Judomaster in a fight,
but the martial arts master is
suddenly gunned down by Leota.
While Leota is unable to pull the trigger on
a former Secret Service agent in Episode 3,
the lectures from Harcourt appear to be making
a difference in her willingness to kill.
"Sure, ignore your God-given natural talent."
We have to imagine her mother would
be pleased by this development.
As the episode comes to a close, Leota is
seen working late at the team headquarters,
when she suddenly recognizes
the logo of a bottling company
named "Glan Tai" on a bulletin board
from the home of Senator Royland Goff.
Searching through the contents of Annie
Sturphausen's purse, she finds an access
card for the same business. There's no doubt
this business is connected to the Butterflies.
Episode 4 is making something clear: However
vile and hateful Peacemaker's father may be,
White Dragon is no fool. Early on in the episode,
Peacemaker retrieves a number of helmets built
by his father and explains to Vigilante
what his father's "closet" actually is.
"It's a quantum unfolding storage area. It leads
to a dimensional nodule outside of normal space."
"I guess your dad's pretty brainy for
a racist to make a place like this."
Later, after succumbing to Leota's
manipulation, Vigilante attempts to
goad White Dragon into attacking him. Though his
fellow white supremacists follow the bait hook,
line and sinker, White Dragon quickly sees
through the ploy and insists that he talk with
Detective Sophie Song. While he has previously
made his hatred for his son abundantly clear,
White Dragon's next moves are sure to even further
complicate their relationship. We have to imagine
that his army of white supremacists aren't
going to take too kindly to Vigilante's attempt
to murder him, especially given his assumption
that Peacemaker orchestrated it. Not to mention,
we'd be very surprised if his supervillain
costume doesn't get some use in the finale.
Around the same time that Vigilante is
released from prison, Murn sits in his
apartment watching the laughing
gas scene from "Lethal Weapon 4."
However, the task force captain appears
entirely emotionless while watching.
Instead of feasting on a bowl of popcorn,
Murn is revealed to be eating the same amber
fluid found at the home of the Butterflies.
The revelation that Murn is actually
a Butterfly is certainly surprising,
but it also makes a lot of sense in the
context of previous events. In Episode 3,
Murn admits to Economos that he is saddened
by the things he has done in the past,
but doesn't go into detail about how he came to
be remorseful and also doesn't appear to be overly
emotional about it. Oddly, he notes that it is the
first time he's ever shared a feeling with anyone.
"Come on, you've never shared any feeling."
"Nope."
"Like you've never even said
like 'oh my god, I'm hungry.'"
"No."
Later, when Peacemaker describes the purple trunks
coming out of the mouths of the Goff family,
Murn doesn't hesitate in delivering an order to
assassinate the senator, his wife and their two
children. Murn's Butterfly status also makes this
moment from early in episode 4 highly suspect.
"It's my dad, man, Jesus. Do you have a f---ing dad?"
"Idid. I wasn't created in a petri dish."
While Murn's exact paternal origins
remain a mystery at this point,
a petri dish no longer sounds
as unlikely as it did before.
Every episode of "Peacemaker" ends with a
post-credits scene that expands on another
scene from the episode that just finished
airing. Episode 4 ends with a return to
White Dragon's quantum unfolding storage area,
where Peacemaker argues with Vigilante over the
troubling connection between Peacemaker's
mission and his father's overt racism.
In the original scene, Peacemaker is
angry when Vigilante proclaims that
"If it walks like a duck, it's either a duck
or a duck wearing some kind of human costume."
Peacemaker insists that couldn't work, noting,
"A duck in a human costume. The
sizes are completely incompatible!"
While he points this out in the original scene,
he goes on at length about
it in the extended edition.
"You've had a lot of f---ing
stupid ideas, but a duck in a human costume,
that's the stupidest idea you've ever f---ing had
and it's offensive to me because I have a soul,"
This definitely seems like a wink-wink moment from
James Gunn, considering that the size difference
between humans and Butterflies is clearly
not an obstacle to their human disguises.
New episodes of "Peacemaker"
drop on HBO Max every Thursday.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Peacemaker
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.